.
>> THE PARTY HAS ITS ROOTS IN
INFASCISM.
BRIAN: THE NEWLY ELECTED PRIME
MINISTER OF ITALY, GIORGIA
MELONI.
THE INTERNATIONAL MEDIA LABELED
HER A FASCIST.
IT'S BIZARRE.
MY NEXT GUEST KNOWS A THING OR
TWO ABOUT STRONG LEADERS BEING
MISINTERPRETED.
NIKKI HALEY.
A BRAND-NEW WORK, IT'S
EXCELLENT.
IF YOU WANT SOMETHING DONE,
LEADERSHIP LESSONS FROM BOLD
WOMEN.
AMBASSADOR, WELCOME BACK.
THE EMERGENCE FROM A FEMALE
PRIME MINISTER IN ITALY.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BELOWBACK.
>> THIS IS WHAT THEY DID TO LIZ
TRUSS, AND IT'S NOW WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TO HER.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE SCARED OF.
THEY ARE CALLING HER A FASCIST.
SHE IS NOT A FASCIST.
SHE DENIED SHE IS PRO RUSSIA.
THEY ARE JUST LABELING HER WITH
STUFF.
WE SHOULD WAIT TO SEE WHAT SHE
DOES.
BRIAN: LIZ TRUSS ALSO TOOK OVER
AS PRIME MINISTER.
>> I THINK SHE IS STRONG.
I WAS WITH HER ABOUT SIX WEEKS
AGO.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY.
SHE IS STRONG.
SHE HAS A SPINE.
I WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT SHE
BACKED OFF THE TAX CUTS SHE
INITIALLY PROPOSED.
BRIAN: SHE WANTED TO CUT TAXES
ON THE RICH BECAUSE THAT PROPELS
THE ECONOMY.
>> IN A TIME WHERE SHE NEEDED TO
DO SOMETHING TO WAKE UP THE
ECONOMY, THAT'S WHAT SHE TRIED
TO DO.
BUT SHE GOT ALL OF THE HEAT
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED TO
MARGARET THATCHER AS WELL.
>> GOLDA MAYOR IS ALSO IN YOUR
BOOK.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO CONSIDER
TO GIVE YOURSELF A YES OR NO
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> WE ARE FOCUSED ON NOVEMBER.
I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IT
UNTIL PROBABLY AFTER JANUARY.
BRIAN: UKRAINE HAS TAKEN 22
VILLAGES AND PROVINCES BACK FROM
RUSSIA.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I BELIEVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT IT COULD BE
ARMAGEDDON.
>> NOT ONLY ARE YOU SOWING FEAR
IN AMERICANS.
BUT THINK ABOUT WHAT PUTIN
THINKS WHEN HE HEARS THAT.
WE NEED TO BE MEASURED.
WE NEED TO BE CLEAR.
IS PUTIN DANGEROUS?
YES.
BUT TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT CREATE
DETERRENT.
WHEN PUTIN TALKS ABOUT NUCLEAR
THREAT AND YOU GO TO CHINA AND
IRAN AND YOU SAY ARE YOU OKAY
WITH THAT CONVERSATION AND HIM
TALKING LIKE THAT AND YOU GET
INTERNATIONAL PRESSURE ON HIM.
PUTIN KNOWS THAT WHAT BIDEN
SHOULD BE SAYING IS IF HE USES A
NUCLEAR WEAPON THERE WILL BE
HELL TO PAY.
YOU DON'T SAY ARMAGEDDON.
WE WOULD DO MISSILE STRIKES, HIT
RUSSIA WHERE IT HURTS AND THEY
WILL RETREAT.
BRIAN: THE STORY OF CHINA
INFILTRATING AMERICA IN TOP
NUCLEAR LABORATORIES TO THE TUNE
OF 162 IN AND AROUND OUR
NATION'S SECRETS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS EXPOSURE.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING HOW THEY
ARE STEALING OUR STUFF, THIS IS
HOW THEY ARE STEALING OUR STUFF.
>> WE MAKE IT SO EASY.
WHEN I WAS AT THE UNITED
NATIONS, WE HAD PEOPLE WHO
WATCHED CHINA'S EVERY MOVE.
UNIVERSITIES HAVE TO STOP TAKING
CHINESE MONEY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ANY CHINESE
EXPERTS OR CHINESE BASICALLY
THERE ON A SCHOLARSHIP.
BRIAN: HOW MANY OF THEM ARE
STUDENTS?
>> NONE.
WE KNOW CHINA IS TRYING THE
STEAL ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM BUYING
FARMLAND NEXT TO MILITARY BASES.
THAT'S WHAT BIDEN NEEDS TO BE
FOCUSING ON.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN TO TAKE ON
CHINA AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE NOT
DOING ANYTHING IN AMERICA.
BRIAN: THE BOOK IS EXCELLENT.
"IF YOU WANT SOMETHING
DONE